und jetzt alle zusammen abholen oder was
die attacke ging darum schock wenn alle
zusammenstehen
du hast recht vielleicht kann seine
freundin ich habe nicht nach würde sich
freuen wenn man man
hilfsbereit
nicht gemeint ich glaube ohne dass man
bei leser nachhilfe gibt das nie was
hatte schon stimmen müssten wirklichen
schutz gebe
bloß nicht bei mir
vega lag
lena mag ich glaube wenn du einen schubs
brauchst dann so einem ganz anderen
thema
zwar nicht wieder mit der eu
ist gerade fand ich dich wirklich ernst
ja ich mich noch gar nicht fertig
gemacht ich werde euch noch zahl
übrigens der junge mann von dem erzählt
hast ja das ist lisa dieses
architekturstudium dass ich sehr
interessant für das was ganz neues
mein vater wird sich natürlich darüber
freuen aber ich habe immer gedacht dass
du dich nie von seinem traum der
schauspielerei verabschieden würde
eine mutter behandelt mich als wäre ich
sie ist ja auch echt noch total jung aus
also ich meine
also ich freue mich auf unseren ausflug
das wird bestimmt super